today the Matt wall show climate
activists have been making a nuisance of
themselves with increasing regularity in
recent weeks besides the obvious
stupidity and need for attention Etc
what is driving all this exactly we'll
talk about that also Elon Musk prepares
to take over Twitter and reportedly fire
75 percent of its staff but Twitter
employees have a plan to stop him a
strongly worded letter and a male
volleyball player who identifies as
female severely injures a female
opponent in our daily cancellation we
have a video that in less than 60
seconds perfectly encapsulates race
relations in America and it's not a
pretty picture all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the labor Department's Consumer Price
Index which catalogs the cost of good
Services food and rent Rose 0.4 percent
over the month of August double what
many economists had anticipated perhaps
worse core inflation which excludes food
and gas prices saw the highest increase
last month that it's seen since August
1982. what is the current Administration
doing to quell The Surge of inflation
spending more taxpayer dollars of course
don't bury your head in the sand while
your savings deplete diversify into gold
with Birch gold today all you got to do
is text Walsh to 989-898 and Birch gold
will send you a free info kit on
protecting your savings with gold in a
tax sheltered account the experts over
at Birch gold have almost 20 years of
experience in converting IRAs and 401ks
into precious metal IRAs with an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
countless five star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers why
haven't you checked them out yet text
Walsh to 989-898 and Birch gold will
send you a free info kit on diversifying
into tax free gold tax uh take the
necessary steps to hedge against
inflation today and protect your
hard-earned money get your free info kit
by texting Walsh to
989898 now
well every few months or so a climate
activists will go through a phase where
they are especially annoying and
obnoxious and of course they're always
annoying and obnoxious but periodically
they will decide to be even more
annoying and obnoxious than usual it
works in Cycles like the phases of the
moon in fact the cycle might even be
tied to the phases of the moon but
that's a theory that will have to be
fleshed out another time the point is
that right now we are going through one
of the extra obnoxious periods here's
their most recent stunt from Yahoo news
it says a protester has been arrested
after just stop oil supporters through
orange paint over the headquarters of a
climate skeptic think tank in central
London climate activists from the
campaign group attacked a building in
Westminster used by the global warming
policy foundation and disrupted traffic
by sitting in the road some supporters
also glued themselves to the road and
others locked themselves together
just stop oil has been demanding the
government halt new oil and gas licenses
and consents it has been um labeled a
nuisance by many and has closed the
Dartford Crossing smeared chocolate cake
over a wax work of King Charles and
thrown various things including mashed
potato over famous pieces of Art in
recent weeks now
we'll leave aside the phrase climate
skeptic as I'm always reminding you that
there are no climate Skeptics nobody is
skeptical about the climate nobody is
walking outside looking up at the clouds
and saying I don't know about this I'm
skeptical we all agree that the climate
exists and that it changes and that
those changes sometimes result in
unfortunate weather events the
skepticism is related to the supposed
causes of those changes and the proposed
solutions for those changes indeed the
the greatest skepticism at least my
greatest skepticism as a skeptic is
directed at the notion that the weather
is a problem that can be solved At All
by anyone apart from God himself but as
I said leave all that to the side we'll
also choose not to linger on the fact
that these climate activists are buying
paint
and throwing it around even though paint
is made from fossil fuels
which is a bit like a vegan activist
purchasing 10 pounds of ground beef from
the supermarket as an active protest
against the slaughter of cows there
seems to be a little bit of a disconnect
here a concept problem but we can't
expect these people to behave rationally
they are throwing a tantrum and if I
know anything about tantruming Toddlers
and I know a lot about them it's that
rationality is well beyond their grasp
especially in the middle of the Tantrum
the episode with the paint is just the
latest in a series of stunts stunts
which often involve throwing different
sorts of liquids onto different sorts of
objects or gluing themselves onto things
last week climate activists glued
themselves to the floor at the Porsche
Museum and the staff at the Museum did
exactly what people should be doing in
response to these sorts of things what
I've been advocating for which is that
they just closed down for the night and
they turned the lights off and the heat
off and they and they just went home and
they left the activists glued to the
floor
the activists then complained that they
weren't provided food
they complained that they weren't given
buckets so that they could go potty uh
it's it's you know it's a bit like
lighting yourself on fire and and in
protest and then complaining that nobody
has a fire extinguisher on hand these
are really the sorts of preparations
that you should probably be making
yourself now elsewhere climate activists
have um blocked traffic they've run onto
the field during sporting events
and most notoriously as mentioned in the
article they've thrown various food
items onto Priceless works of art this
apparently led to um some internal
disputes among climate activists as
reported by axios with this interesting
headline headline is climate activists
divided on souping art
souping yes soup is a verb now
soup is something that you can do
because you know there are no rules in
English language as we have repeatedly
discovered the article says
quote 18 year old climate activist
Elijah McKenzie Jackson campaign
coordinator for youth climate strike
movement Fridays for future
International told axios in an email
that history tells us civil protests
like these are necessary for change
he says quote although I can recognize
these acts of Justice may seem
outrageous to people I challenge them to
feel the outrage of Destruction death
and murder all Western governments and
corporations are committing to our
animals our neighbors in the South and
our ecosystems
wrote Mackenzie Jackson 15 year old
Genesis Butler founder of global
organization youth climate save echoed
that sentiment writing in an email to
axios that quote it's important for us
all to make bold moves to raise
awareness about the climate crisis
but then there's the other side some
don't see putting fabled art at the
heart of disruptive protests as an
effective path to advancing climate
action among those who spoke out against
the van Gogh soup stunt was climate
scientist Michael Mann who criticized
the move telling the Associated Press
that people will draw negative
associations with climate active
advocacy
he's worried that they will draw those
negative associations I think it's a
little bit too late for that researchers
and journalists alike have also since
argued that these kinds of viral
activities don't mitigate climate
polluting emissions
science and policy do
oh well it's good that researchers have
made that determination I would not have
been able to figure that out otherwise
we needed researchers to tell us that
throwing tomato soup on an old painting
will not change the weather
that's what researchers are saying I
need to see the studies I haven't read
the studies for myself
I won't believe it I need to see show me
the study
that proves
you can't change the temperature outside
by throwing your food at a painting
but if soup will not alter the climate
maybe dancing will after all many
primitive cultures have believed that
dancing has some effect on the weather
and maybe they were on to something
these Healthcare professionals seem to
think so so they performed a rendition
of staying alive in pursuit of climate
Justice let's watch this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stay alive
[Music]
stay alive
[Music]
we all want to stay alive they sing
though I'm not sure I do after hearing
that I'm having flashbacks now to covid
when the nurses wouldn't stop dancing
and uh which ultimately you know did you
know covet ended up being worse than the
black plague as they predicted because
the nurses were dancing so much and back
in the black plague the healthcare
professionals they didn't do as much
dancing
I can only hope this doesn't become a
trend again because of climate change so
what is this all about
uh why are the climate activists having
these tantrums whether a musical form or
not um well one thing we must always
keep in mind is that nothing is or
entirely organic on the left there is
money behind this current rash of
activism organizations funding it and
pulling the strings
and that's especially true when you hear
about we heard in the axios article
about a 15 year old who who started an
international organization
um it's uh
almost always the case that when you
hear about it it's just like when kids
in Virginia the kids in Virginia were
staging uh walkouts in their schools all
across the state because of uh you know
policies that say that only boys boys
have to use the boys room and girls have
to use the girls room then you find out
that well I know this is all being
organized by adults and by organizations
with money so the same thing goes here
but as for the grunts on the ground you
know people that are out there actually
gluing themselves to the floor or having
food fights with arctic art exhibits or
whatever else
there's not one explanation that can
suffice
for some of them this is empty virtue
signaling they're hopping on a trend
fishing for social media clout Etc
there's definitely a lot of that
and for some of them the younger ones
anyway
this is the youthful rebellious Instinct
searching for a Cause
young people naturally desire a cause to
protest over fight for or against and
climate activism provides an outlet just
it's a place to expend that energy
but underneath all of that I think
there's also nihilism
this is the engine that drives most
so-called climate activism
that's it's really the message that
they're sending when they destroy or
attempt to destroy a Priceless work of
art or when they block traffic randomly
interfering with people's ability to get
to work and feed their families and at
the same time creating more traffic
congestion which only causes more CO2
emissions not less
what does that achieve
well nothing of course
it is just destruction and obstruction
for its own sake
it's a protest not really against
climate change but against life Against
Humanity they are expressing their anger
at a world that to them has no meaning
they're expressing their anger at the
fact that at the fact that it has no
meaning
you know so some of these people again
the younger ones especially they really
do believe that the world is coming to
an end
they really believe it
now a lot of the a lot of the older
people the adults uh the Hollywood
celebrities that push this stuff and
they're flying around in the private
jets and Al Gore and you know we know
about all the Hypocrites behind this of
it and they don't really believe it they
know but they're the ones who who
started this they're the ones who are
propagating the LIE
the ones propagating the LIE they know
that it's a lie
I mean a lot of these kids don't know
that
they've been told since they were
children
that the world's coming to an end
because of this
the the fear tactics the hysteria that's
all settled into their minds
but they also see no value
in life
and in the planets which they believe is
headed towards destruction
and this tension is what causes them to
lash out like they do in the way that
they do
I mean think about that's why it's kind
of it's it's interesting that they're
going after paintings you would think
that uh if you believed that the world
was coming to an end and that we didn't
have much time left you would cherish
beautiful art even more you know you
would have more appreciation for the
things that are beautiful in the world
but they don't because underneath all
this is nihilism lack of meaning denial
of meeting
that's what lies at the bottom of all
left-wing causes
and this one is certainly no exception
now let's get to our five headlines
well as you all know I'm currently
waging a war with a force diametrically
opposed to everything I believe in I'm
not referring to the culture war or my
ceaseless battle with the gender
ideologues this war is one waged at home
literally I can't get my giant walrus
home because my wife doesn't want it
there
I have no idea where this is going day
after day I passed the gentle creature
sitting solemnly in the corner his eyes
following me I look away in a mixture of
Anguish and shame disheartening and
inescapable concoction of emotion is
overwhelming all the while I still feel
his longing stare as I leave each day
without him in tow
going to have we're gonna have to vacuum
seal it like a mattress or something but
I'm open to suggestions because this
fight is far from over
where the hell is this going go to
dailywire.com shop to bring home your
owners okay yours will not come vacuum
sealed but it will fit through the door
just fine
so Elon Musk is scheduled to take the
reins over at Twitter I believe on
Friday uh that's when the deal is
supposed to be official and he'll
actually be in charge of Twitter
um the left obviously is panicking over
it and and they're panicking because we
know they rely so much on on
suppressing speech and and and
that is all in service to kind of this
manuf pretending that there are that
there is a consensus on an issue when
there really isn't as some people have
called it on Twitter you know
manufacturing a consensus
um that's the Great Value that uh that
Twitter has for the left and that all
social media does that big Tech has for
them
is by pretending you know by by putting
their own views out there and pretend
and creating an environment where it
seems like everyone agrees with their
position when really they don't
um it's a
and that can be a very convincing thing
to people when they when we spend so
much time on social media and there's
one point of view that you see
everywhere you turn
and another point of view which might be
your own which you don't see represented
at all trick you into believing that uh
well you must be very much in the
minority and if you're in the minority
you must be wrong
but they manufacture this by suppressing
all other opinions
now they're afraid that's going to go
out the window
um so Elon Musk showed up to Twitter
headquarters yesterday uh and he posted
a quick video showing him carrying a
sink into the building here's that video
it's not good because he let that sink
in is it is it the pun
I think it's I'm always a fan of I'm
always an apologist for all forms of uh
dad jokes now we previously talked about
musk's reported plan to fire a huge
portion of the staff which is a great
idea it's even a better idea than the
pun and the pun was a fantastic idea
um and it's an even better idea in light
of this here's a video that lives of
tick tock found and posted this is
another one of those Tick Tock videos
where somebody goes through their daily
routine I have no idea why this is a
trend
why these videos are so popular but they
are so here is the daily routine
of a Twitter employee watch
welcome to a day in my life as a Twitter
employee so this past week went to SF
for the first time at a Twitter office
badged in honestly took a moment to just
soak everything in what a blessing also
started my morning off with an iced
matcha from the perch then I had a
meeting so it's quickly scheduled one of
these little pod rooms which were so
cool they're literally noise canceling
took my meeting got ready for a bunch
look how delicious this food looks oh my
goodness I was so overwhelmed then made
my way down to this Log Cabin area I
don't know what this is but it was
really cool I played some food smell
with my friends to kind of unwind a bit
um also found this really cool
meditation room that I thought was super
neat
um I didn't do any yoga but they have
this yoga room if you are a yogi so I
also thought that was really cool
um had a couple more meetings in the
afternoon had a ton of projects that we
needed to knock out say hi to my
teammates
um went to the went to the library to
kind of get some more work done
obviously had to have our afternoon
coffee so made some espresso and then
before leaving for the day I had some
red wine
um that's on tap went up to the rooftop
and just honestly enjoyed the beautiful
weather so awesome trip
that no work but it was done at all well
she had a meeting so we had a meeting
for 15 minutes
I think there's a lot of fat we can trim
here I really think that there is so he
wants to fire 75 employees I think he
probably fired 90 and we would be fine
uh I love how she says that she had to
unwind by playing some foosball with her
friends
unwind you just you just got you got to
work an hour ago
you spent most of the time drinking
coffee and hanging out and meditating
and you already have to unwind
if you have time for yoga and foosball
and meditation during the work day you
aren't needed okay good rule of thumb
there if I was an employer I I might put
all of that stuff in the office just so
that I can fire whoever uses it
gives people an opportunity to sort of
tell on themselves I think it's actually
a brilliant idea the more that I think
about this
it's really not a bad idea have a have a
swimming pool have a hot tub have a
water park uh have lounge chairs and
reading material and
you know all that kind of stuff
have a room that says like the it's the
uh it's the the Netflix room you just
sit there and browse Netflix and watch
Netflix movies
and anyone caught using any of that is
fired automatically
I'm half joking well I'm not really
joking at all I would do that but the
point is that if you don't want to be
fired if you want to have job security
and this is not just a lesson for
Twitter employees it's for everybody you
have to make yourself Irreplaceable as
Irreplaceable as possible I mean the
reality is that nobody is totally
Irreplaceable but your value to your
employer increases with the degree of
your ear replaceability okay
um if they can find
just anyone off the street to do your
job then you have almost no value
as an employee
sadly
it's just that's the reality of it it's
not very might not be nice to think
about but it is
if they can find anyone else if they
pull anybody else in and have them do it
then you don't you just don't have a lot
of value
now if they would have extreme
difficulty finding someone who can bring
what you bring to the table then you
have immense value
which means you have bargaining power
and you have leverage
speaking of which I just saw the uh so
Starbucks has a a union now the
Starbucks employees have unionized
and uh they were complaining earlier
this week because they were they were
trying to have a meeting with uh with
twit with a Starbucks management you
know Starbucks corporate management and
the corporate walked out of the meeting
they complained and they said they just
got up and walked out they wouldn't they
wouldn't negotiate
well this again goes back to you have to
have leverage you have to have
bargaining power
and if you work at Starbucks for example
like there's there are a lot of people
who can do that and so you just don't
have a lot of Leverage
Twitter employees especially don't
understand this understand this um
and what they think is they can just
make demands so this is from time
okay Time Magazine has this employees at
Twitter are circulating an open letter
protesting Elon musk's plan to fire as
much as 75 percent of the company's
Workforce as the deadline for him to
complete his 44 billion dollar
acquisition of the company looms time
has learned
musk must complete the acquisition by
Friday or face the resumption of a
lawsuit in Delaware Court
um and uh it the plan is that he will
eradicate the jobs of nearly 75 percent
of Twitter staff reducing headcount from
7 500 to Just 2 000.
according to Washington Post now here's
the letter that they're circulating it
says
staff Elon Musk and board of directors
we the underside Twitter workers believe
the public conversation is in jeopardy
Elon musk's plan it's the public
conversation is in jeopardy
because it's not going to be suppressed
anymore
the public conversation is in Jeopardy
when more people are allowed to
participate in it
it's very similar to how we're going to
face the end of democracy if too many
Republicans participate in it and vote
for Republicans that's the end of
democracy
so it's the end of the public
conversation if there are too many
people involved in the conversation
Elon musk's plan to lay off 75 percent
of Twitter workers will hurt Twitter's
ability to serve the public conversation
a threat of this magnitude is reckless
undermines our users and customers trust
in our platform and is a transparent Act
of worker intimidation
Twitter has significant effects on
societies and communities across the
globe as we speak Twitter is helping to
uplift independent journalism in Ukraine
and Iran as well as powering social
movements around the world a threat to
workers at Twitter is a threat to
Twitter's Future these threats have an
impact on us as workers and demonstrate
a fundamental disconnect with the
realities of operating Twitter they
threaten our livelihoods access to
essential Healthcare and the ability for
Visa holders to stay in the country they
work in we cannot do our work in an
environment of constant harassment and
threats without our work there is no
Twitter well yeah but we're which is
the point is that many of you don't need
to do your work anymore because you're
going to be fired so I don't even
understand if you fire us we will not be
able to do our work at Twitter well yeah
that's the whole point we don't you're
not needed
we the workers at Twitter will not be
intimidated we recommit to supporting
the communities organizations and
businesses who rely on Twitter we will
not stop serving the public conversation
well you will if you get fired
then you will
that's how it works we call on Twitter
management and Elon Musk to cease these
negligent layoff threats as workers we
deserve concrete commitment so we can
continue to preserve the Integrity of
our platform we demand of current and
future leadership respect we demand a
leadership to respect the platform and
the workers who maintain it by
committing to preserving the current
head count
safety we demand that leadership does
not discriminate against workers on the
basis of their race gender disability
sexual orientation or political beliefs
oh now they're worried about people
being discriminated against based on
based on political beliefs we also
demand safety for workers on visas we
will be forced to leave the country or
who will be first to leave the country
if they work
um they're working if they're laid off
protection we demand Elon Musk
explicitly commit to preserve our
benefits those both listed in the merger
agreement and not we demand leadership
to establish and ensure Fair Severance
policies for all workers before and
after any change in ownership we demand
transparent prompt and thoughtful
communication around our working
conditions we demand to be treated with
dignity and to not be treated as mere
Pawns in a game played by billionaires
okay again these demands mean nothing if
you have no Leverage
and notice how they they never even
try to pretend that they have leverage
they didn't say
here's what we bring to the company okay
here's what we do every day
um and and you need us to do this and
here's what will happen if you get rid
of us hear all the bad things will
happen to the company
um into the company's bottom line
without us
okay here's what will happen if you
don't have us doing yoga and eating
hummus all day this these are this is
this is the catastrophe that we'll do
they didn't really do that instead they
just went right to playing the victim
card emotional blackmail
if you fire us
it'll make us feel bad
that's their argument
you know it's just it probably won't
work if you get called into the office
and the boss lets you know listen it's
not working out we got to go our
separate ways you can't do that why
can't I do it
because I don't like it
it makes me it makes me feel bad to be
fired
okay well
sorry to hear that
anyway here's your box fill it with
stuff and get the hell out please
um
just that you can you can make demands
all you want but the demand doesn't mean
anything if you have no Leverage
and leverage as an employer is tied to
what you actually do to how you perform
to what you bring to the table
the problem is that a lot of these
people have been told that it doesn't
matter what they do it doesn't matter
what they bring to the table they
shouldn't have to prove themselves to
anyone
and they should be allowed to continue
working at Twitter just because because
it's it's they they are them and they
are special
just doesn't work that way unfortunately
all right
so the Washington Post has this story
headline Democrats scramble into
defensive posture in final stage of
midterms it says Democrats on Wednesday
pumped at least 6.3 million dollars
worth of advertising into a trio of
congressional districts in New Jersey
and New York where President Biden won
by at least eight percentage points
first lady Jill Biden spent the
afternoon in Rhode Island trying to help
save a Democrat running in a district
her husband carried by nearly 14 points
oh that'll do it that is the Democrats
secret weapon heading into the midterms
they're very worried they're in a
defensive posture they're panicking
there might be the Red Wave but they're
trotting out their secret weapon which
is Jill Biden that'll get the voters
turned up it will the president is
headed to the deep blue Empire State on
Thursday where the Democratic governor
is scrambling to avoid an upset in a
closer than expected race that has put
Democrats down the ballot in Greater
danger and Pennsylvania Democrats were
trying to move past a shaky Tuesday
debate performance by John fetterman
shaky is one way to put it
um one former Party official relayed
hearing from people who wondered why
fetterman agreed to debate during his
recovery in the first place so it's just
and these are the and when the media is
reporting this you know that it's bad
when even the media is saying the
Democrats are panicking and it's not
looking good for the Democrats you know
it's a bad situation
um and why are why are we headed towards
a red wave
you know why are Democrats in this spot
well it's for one thing because as we
talked about yesterday we've talked
about many times
Democrats are not focused
on the issues that not only just the
issues people care about but the issues
that actually affect people the for the
Democrats their their entire platform
all they have to offer is ideology
that's it
and the reality is that most Americans
are not intensely ideological
which sometimes we have to remind as
those of us who are ideological and kind
of live in the political space
that could come as a surprise to us
but it's just the truth
that's not to say that most people are
stupid or that or or uninformed I mean
there are a lot of uninformed people out
there but
um being not very ideological and being
uninformed are not the same
and that's just it people people tend to
be more focused on just the realities of
everyday life and you know the the
meeting the needs of their families and
that sort of thing
um Democrats have nothing to offer you
there
they need you to be
fully they need you to buy in fully to
the leftist ideological project and then
they can speak to you if you have bought
in then they can speak to you but if you
haven't they don't even have the
language to speak to you
I also think related to this that you
know after uh Rovio Wade was overturned
and there was this discussion about who
does this help
and the the consensus was that this is
going to help the Democrats that Roe v
Wade has overturned and it's going to
lead to uh in fact there's there's going
to be a wave it's gonna be a massive
Blue Wave
um because Roe v waves returned it's
going to motivate voters to get out
there and vote to protect their quote
abortion rights and I did tell you from
the very beginning that that is that
that is not going to happen
okay now back earlier in the summer I
was skeptical myself about whether the
Red Wave would materialize
but that to me had nothing to do with
Roe v Wade overturned in fact I said
from the beginning that in truth
um abortion is not that high on the list
of of most Americans concerns
and I lament that myself as a pro-life
right I I think Americans should care
more about it from a pro-life
perspective
but they don't
you know and the con polling
consistently shows that
you ask people to list the the things
that they're worried about the issues
they care about and abortion is going to
cut like barely even cracks the top five
for most people for me it's higher up
again because I am an avid pro-lifer
but that's it most people don't care
about it that much
and so and this is before Roe v Wade was
overturned this was the this was the
fundamental challenge that pro-lifers
faced
yeah we had to make our case we had to
explain you know we we were we were
defending
the rights of unborn babies to exist to
live their right to life
but before we could even get to that
point
we had to get over the apathy the kind
of General uh malaise and indifference
that people have around this issue
and that is and we spent decades dealing
with that problem it's very difficult to
overcome
and now the left is experiencing the
same thing
so they were expecting that this would
motivate voters and it just didn't
which means that ultimately Roe v Wade
getting overturned has helped
Republicans
it's helped Republicans not because it's
motivated voters on the other side no
but just because it uh Roe v Wade
getting being overturned has led to
Democrats deciding that they should make
abortion into you know one of the
central parts of their platform
it has led to Democrats focusing on
abortion leading into the election which
if if Roe v Wade had not been overturned
they would not have focused on it as
much
but it was
they assumed that that Americans would
be very concerned about that and so they
have made that their focus
and it has hurt them considerably
all right this is from
a story from outkick that's been uh
following this story here it says the
mainstream Sports media continues to
blur the lines between men's and women's
Athletics without much consideration for
the potential dangers of having
biologically different athletes
competing against each other a North
Carolina High School volleyball match
last month highlighted the ugly side of
this narrative when a trans female who
is biologically male
spike the ball so hard that it hit a
female opponent in the face and bound
several feet back into the net the girl
suffered significant head and neck
injuries along with a concussion
um so this happened
a couple of weeks ago didn't get a lot
of attention in fact I don't even think
that I mentioned it for me it just got
you know when it comes to the assault on
uh on biological reality and gender
ideology there are so many things
happening all at once that uh that
things end up getting lost in the
shuffle but this this
this did this did occur you know we're
told that
having biological males compete against
females it's a it's you know it's not
hurting anybody
of course that's always a lie
and uh even putting aside physical
injury
were hurting Girls by taking
opportunities away from them
and we're taking their privacy away from
them in the locker rooms
but then there is also of course the
potential for actual physical injury
which is what happened here
uh continues out kick was one of the few
media entities which extensively
reported on the incident the
controversial play in early September
during the match between hawasi Dam high
school and Highlands High School quote
shows the female volleyball player
getting hit and collapsing and then
staying down for a substantial amount of
time
outkick continues incredibly a YouTube
user posted the video on their page as a
career highlight for the trans
volleyball player this is a highlight
now
the video slows down draws a green
circle around the player and then shows
the vicious Spike Hitting off the face
of the young female with a shocking
velocity
um and so this is now circulating on
YouTube I guess it's not known for
certain that the trans player who did
this is the one who put the video up
could probably assume that I don't know
who else would
but this is now being counted as a as an
athletic highlight for this player
viciously injuring a a woman
and of course does the player care that
this
girl was injured we can assume not
because they never do
you know that's if they cared about the
female athletes they wouldn't be there
in the first place
if they were taking into consideration
the safety the feelings the perspective
of the real female athletes they're
compete against they wouldn't be there
competing against them in the first
place the fact that they're there means
that they don't care they're just not
take into consideration I wanted to
mention this briefly as well this is
from the Intelligencer it says a second
woman has come forward to accuse
Herschel Walker the Republican Senate
canon in Georgia who has compared
abortion to murder of pressuring her
into getting an abortion three decades
ago in a press conference held by
celebrity attorney Gloria Allred on
Wednesday in Los Angeles the anonymous
woman claimed that when she was carrying
her his child uh he demanded that she
terminate her pregnancy going so far as
to take her to abortion clinic
to see it through she said quote I don't
I don't believe Herschel is morally fit
to be a U.S senator and that is the
reason I'm speaking up and providing
proof
bearing on a blank screen on Zoom to
protect herself from what she feared
would be reprisals the woman said she
was romantically involved for six years
with Walker during his NFL days
hopscotching from game to game with him
well he was married to his first wife
she learned that she was pregnant in
April of 1993 when the two were living
in Dallas and he played for the Cowboys
Walker according to Allred gave her cash
to pay for an abortion but when she
arrived at the clinic she was overcome
with emotion and left the woman said
Walker was upset she didn't go through
with the procedure and the next day
drove to her drove her to a clinic and
waited outside until it was done an
apologetic note from Walker followed
according to all red but he immediately
distanced himself from her okay so this
is a claim
from an anonymous woman
relating to something that allegedly
happened three decades ago when Herschel
Walker was still actually playing in the
NFL
and we are getting this through Gloria
Allred
it is just it's really kind of amazing
to me
that women who were making accusations
and want to be taken seriously are still
going to Gloria Allred
do you not understand which I guess you
don't
that the moment Gloria Allred is
involved
most people immediately dismiss it
and for good reason
because she's a grifter and a fraud
and a scam artist
so if you're if you're teaming up with
Glory all right I'm just not interested
in what you have to say you want to be
taken seriously go somewhere else
you know find a different lawyer it
doesn't need to be Gloria Allred
although you're gonna have trouble dig
into being taken seriously when you're
coming out two weeks before an election
30 years later
to make a claim for which you have no
evidence
um
if if you want to make a claim against
someone
you've got some time within that 30-year
period
you know it would be better to come
forward when you when you wait until two
weeks before an election you're just not
going to be taken seriously as simple as
that variety has this story Harvey
Weinstein's defense told the jury uh
during his trial that there is
absolutely no evidence against their
client and that every woman who will
testify in his trial is an actress who
will be playing a role on the stand uh
all to fit The Narrative of me too which
they characterized as an asteroid of a
movement that burst forth like a
supernova with Weinstein as the poster
child
uh Weinstein's attorney Mark worksman
told jurors that they should prepare to
hear a fire hose of false and
unproofable allegations from women who
agreed to have consensual sexual
interactions with Weinstein but years
later are now embarrassed and lying
about what really happened
look at my client worksman said point of
Weinstein he's not Brad Pitt or George
Clooney do you think these beautiful
women had sex with him because he's hot
no it's because he's powerful
weinste's attorney told the jury that
Hollywood has changed today but back in
the day transactional sex was par for
the course
sex was a commodity for Rich and
powerful men like my client Weinstein's
attorney said even getting its own
nickname the casting couch
so that's the uh that's the defense that
they're offering now in this new trial
for Harvey Weinstein is that this is you
know the transactional sex everyone did
it
I don't doubt one part of what he says
um all the stuff about being him being
innocent
that's nonsense of course
um but one part it doesn't achieve what
he seems to want to achieve which is to
excuse the fact that he's a raping
scumbag who will and should die in
prison
uh and probably should get the death
penalty otherwise not
doesn't mitigate his own guilt he's just
as evil as he ever was
um everyone was doing it is always a bad
excuse It's especially a bad excuse when
we're talking about sex crimes
but it is certainly true that Hollywood
was and still is crawling with sexual
deviance and people who use sex to
exploit and control and gain power men
and women both
um the claim that transactional sex was
the norm yeah I believe that
still is probably even though they tell
us that oh Hollywood's cleanup is act
tend to doubt that and a lot worse than
transactional sex in fact Weinstein
didn't invent it
um
you know they're they're presenting him
as a sort of a sacrificial goat that was
offered up Kevin Spacey is another one
that's made that claim
and in a sense sure it's like it's like
any mob movie if someone's gonna be the
Fall Guy he's got to be high enough on
the ladder to make everyone feel like
they solved the problem by getting rid
of him in the case of Weinstein and
Spacey
um problems were solved by getting rid
of them I mean people that they would
have abused and victimized in the future
now have been protected from that but
there's no reason to think that the
underlying problem has gone away or that
all of the offenders or even the worst
offenders were actually caught in the
net
I mean think about it Jeffrey Epstein
was arrested and quote unquote killed
himself right around when all these
metoo stuff was happening and yet how
many of Epstein's Associates have been
arrested how many of his clients
they have a they have a book listing his
clients how many of them have been
arrested how many of his high profile
wealthy powerful clients in Hollywood
media government have been taken down
none zero not one
I mean it's it's amazing Epstein was a
wealthy globetrotting sex trafficker who
evidently trafficked to nobody
nobody's been arrested how does that
work
so yeah there are a lot of other fish in
the sea that we should be catching
bigger fish too probably
but um Harvey Weinstein
was the uh
one of the few scumbags in Hollywood
they during the metoo movement it was
kind of like they were you know all
these sexual deviants and generates and
predators and they selected a few from
this group that would have to go down
and good riddance they deserve it
the only problem is all the other
weinsteins that are still out there
and will remain because you know we've
just moved on and pretended that the
problem of sexual deviance in Hollywood
was somehow solved and of course it was
all right let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
[Music]
Jay Lambert says I'm 100 in support of
being ableist and ageist when voting I
don't care about a wheelchair or an eye
patch or whatever but I definitely want
a person without mental limitations and
you don't have to be pre-retirement per
se but I don't want a person who is so
old that they have become senile and
incontinent yeah that's what if that's
what ableist at Aegis means then yes
that is uh we we should we should bring
that into really every area of our life
which is just wrecking as I said
yesterday recognizing
people's limitations everybody has
limitations so recognizing what those
limitations are
and especially if you're selecting
someone to fulfill some sort of role
whether the role is President United
States or anything else uh you got to
keep those limitations in mind
that's ableism and ageism now like okay
well then that's I guess that's what we
are
uh Nadeem says if Hallmark did their
research they would know that Matt
became even less of a germaphobe after
covet that's that's exactly right that's
the so in the in the uh the the
character playing Matt face and the
Hallmark
film yesterday there was germaphobe
didn't want to shake hands
now I was never afraid of shaking
people's hands but but before covet I
probably would have identified myself as
in some ways a germaphobe but my my
contrarian nature took over and so
during covet when when everyone else
became a germaphobe I actually became
less of one
uh I am done says I had a stroke two
years ago and have had lasting effects
from it fortunately for me I didn't
suffer cognitive damage but instead have
other physical issues as a result of
these physical issues you would not hire
me to be a professional baseball pitcher
that's not ableism but rather
recognition of actual limitations
fetterman is suffering from cognitive
issues the position that he's wanting to
be elected to requires that he have full
cognitive abilities to recognize that he
doesn't is not ableism it's reality well
you know one of the one of the excuses
now that we're hearing from Democrats
is that he doesn't actually have
cognitive defects he can still
understand everything fine it's just
that he can't he can't communicate
which even if that were true
inability to communicate
in the legislature you'd think would be
rather important
but also it's it
how could we know if that's true
you know it's it's hard their claim is
that he still has he still understands
he's just not able to communicate but we
don't know how much he understands
because he can't communicate
and so it's just a question of whether
or not you want to roll the dice and put
them in the Senate anyway
which of course we shouldn't
um
Rose says you know Matt we're quickly
approaching the Christmas season and
I'll be reminded yet again of how the
pampering of oddballs in society began
which was Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer
and that animated television special two
non-conforming characters are shown to
suffer thus making their Social Circle
feel guilty and they're then embraced
for the features which made them objects
of shock and dismay their society's
exterior threat is literally defanged by
the two weirdos and is rehabilitated in
a sort of demasculinization surgery then
as a cherry on top unintended everyone
is forced to make accommodations for
various Oddities in the shape of damaged
toys handed out by awoke Santa I think
this planted the seed for the exaltation
of victimhood
change my mind
I'm not going to change mine because I
could not agree more
I couldn't I couldn't agree more I mean
first of all
Rudolph in the show
is J it is just lame he's annoying and
lame I wouldn't want to hang out with
him either
is a grading personality and then it
turns out that he's also hideously
deformed
I mean you got to give people something
right if you're going to have the
deformity at least compensate with a
good personality if you don't check any
box at all then like what do you expect
the other reindeer to do of course
they're not going to invite you to play
their reindeer games
and by the way is it really reasonable
to expect
that people won't point and laugh when
your nose literally lights up like a
light bulb what's the expectation here
that they're going to see that and go oh
your nose lights up cool no problem and
then just go about their day like you
know that's
I actually think that the other reindeer
in the show handled it pretty well all
things considered
I don't know it's like if the daily wire
hired some guy he came to my office
first of all just coming to my office
would be a problem but he shows up and
he's got this huge freakish light up
nose
I would go and demand that he's fired
it's a distraction it's disturbing
could be contagious for all I know
couldn't agree more
uh let's get now to the Daily
cancellation
[Music]
well if I had to explain race relations
in America to someone who just crawled
out of a cave that they've been living
in since birth or to someone who simply
relies on the corporate media for their
information which is effectively the
same thing as living in a cave I think
that I would probably show them this
it's a clip making the rounds on the
internet though it was initially
produced a few years ago by a YouTube
channel called Jubilee in fact it's from
the year 2019 which means that the
sickness that it inadvertently reveals
has only gotten worse
2020 was uh was the year that broke many
white people who had not yet been broken
and further broke the ones who were
already broken and so this this was
right before that in the clip which is
harvested from two longer videos a group
of black people and then a group of
white people are asked to react to the
statement I am proud to be black or I am
proud to be white respectable and then
by walking to different sides of the
room they must indicate whether they
agree or disagree with that statement so
you can already sort of guess where this
is going but let's watch
I am proud to be black
three two one
well all right yeah
I'm glad that we all strongly agree I am
proud to be white
three
two
one
to be in the middle yeah can there be a
middle
[Music]
like I'm like happy that I'm not
oppressed but I'm not proud of like
things people have done in the past when
I when I think of being proud of
something I think of something I worked
for
so as expected the uh black group has no
problem walking immediately to the
strongly agree section indicating that
they are indeed very proud to be black
but the white group is hesitant to
answer at all uh deathly afraid that
whatever they do or say might end up
being racist ultimately most of the room
decides that they are not proud to be
white while even a couple of brave souls
who go to the agree side of the room
still admit that they feel guilty about
their answer
now you might argue as the dude in the
jean jacket begins to argue at the end
of the video that being proud of your
race doesn't really make any sense now
how could you be proud of something you
didn't accomplish what does it mean to
be proud of a characteristic you were
born with or a situation you were born
into
isn't Pride something that should be
rightly reserved for actual achievements
things that we strive for things we earn
now I'm sympathetic to that argument
though this definition of pride would
also preclude most of us from saying
that we're proud to be Americans
I was born in this country I didn't work
for or achieve my citizenship so can I
not say I'm proud to be an American it
would also mean that we can't say we're
proud of our families or of our
communities
in fact very often we use the word proud
to describe our feelings about things
that we didn't actively and personally
accomplish
maybe that means that we should be using
a different word in all these contexts
perhaps rather than saying proud to be
we should be saying happy to be or
grateful to be
this is all academic because whether it
makes logical sense to be proud of your
race or not the point brought forth in
the video is that only white people feel
uncomfortable saying so
the attitude in our culture is that it's
okay to be proud of your race more than
okay
unless you're white
the longer version of the video makes
this clear as one of the subjects
explains that it's actually racist for
white people to be proud of their
whiteness but it's not racist for black
people to be proud of their Blackness
and here's why
it's like saying I'm a proud white
person is a completely different saying
than saying I'm a proud black person
because when you hear I'm a proud black
person I think empowerment I think
strength I think courage I think you
know all these amazing things that the
black community has done and
accomplished throughout the years but
then when you say I am a straw or I'm a
proud white person
already there's so much like hate
involved in that
there's hate involved in being proud of
yourself if you're white
she says that black people have
accomplished many things through the
years and so when they say they're proud
to be black uh that's what they're proud
of
but white people have accomplished many
things as well many of the greatest
scientists innovators inventors
explorers discoverers philosophers
leaders artists civil rights Heroes Have
Been whites so can we not be proud of
that again if you want to argue that
it's technically illogical for anyone to
have pride tied to the race
that's a perfectly consistent position
but that is not what the people in the
video are saying and it's not what our
culture teaches us or conditions us to
believe we're told that pride in your
race is a privilege that white people
are not granted because rather than
being proud We ought to be racked with
guilt and shame I mean that's the
message
elsewhere in the video they also debate
whether white people have a culture
here's what they say
people have culture
three two one
we're all technically white if you're
from England if you're from Australia if
you're from wherever South Africa you
know we all have these crazy places we
come from and these people are around
and we get those ideas from those people
but that doesn't mean us as a whole have
no culture but as a white person it's
not really a culture you can have
culture like I'm hella Irish obviously
and that's a culture but that just being
white is not a it's it's not a culture I
can't relate to you just because you're
white I think you could say that for any
ethnicity though if we were all black
could I relate to you guys if just
because of the color of our skin yes
because they go through very similar
experiences like they'll get
discriminated against and you're not
getting discriminated against because of
your skin color they can both relate to
that but I also feel like with culture
we Branch out we try different things we
want to do different things so maybe
we've lost a little bit of our culture
maybe we're creating a new culture there
you go
now again it's true that the term white
is very Broad and encompasses many
different backgrounds and cultural
Traditions but the same is true of black
a black person could be from various
continents dozens of different countries
so if it makes sense to say that a black
person born in Cincinnati whose family
has been here for five generations
somehow shares Black Culture with
someone who lives in Kenya and that
those those two are of one culture with
a black guy in Jamaica then uh why can't
white people have a culture too
jean jacket man in the video says that
the difference is oppression and racism
all black people experience oppression
and racism while white people don't this
becomes the default answer to explain
away any double standard inconsistency
and how the races are treated someone
just shouts racism and that's supposed
to answer the question but the answer
assumes first of all that it's true that
white people don't experience racism
but it's not true we'll get back to that
in a moment it also assumes that
experiencing racism being victims counts
as a culture it doesn't
speaking of racism the participants are
asked about that subject as well can
white people be victims of racism and
here's how they answered
three
two one
I don't know what that is we can explain
it I'll stay here
Reverse Racism is like someone being
racist against you because you are white
like do you believe that someone can be
racist against a white person
yeah I grew up where it was completely
like Hispanic culture I was constantly
made fun of because I was white oh white
people can't dance white people look
stupid whatever they shouldn't say white
people can't dance but they can't yeah
putting that out there but I mean like
being honest though like they would say
those mean things to me and more hurtful
things than that it's like a hard pill
to swallow because if I turned around
said black people can't dance I'd get
hell for that but then if someone says
the same words to me it's somehow okay
because you have to look at the
difference of it though and I relate to
you I grew up with all Latino or black
friends I had very few white friends and
yeah I got made fun of for being like
the white girl I was gringott and I
didn't take offense to it because the
huge part about
racism is that there's hate and
oppression behind it and as a white
person in America I do not feel
oppressed
it's hard to watch uh to be clear I
don't believe in Reverse Racism either
there is just racism so when a black
person hates a white person that isn't
Reverse Racism it's just racism the very
phrase Reverse Racism assumes that
racism itself is a white invention
which it is not racism is simply hating
someone or thinking less of them because
of their race it's the belief that a
certain race is inferior to your own
that's racism and that's a belief
harbored by by some members of every
race
um and direct it out towards every other
race
if you travel outside of the
predominantly white Western World you'll
find explicit Unapologetic racism
everywhere you go cultures where they
hate other races and don't even bother
hiding it
the fascinating thing in the video is
that the woman arguing against the
existence of quote unquote Reverse
Racism actually admits that she has been
hated and mocked for her race yet she
says that doesn't count as racism
in fact she doesn't even take offense to
it she says
she will stand there and allow herself
to be spit on and belittled for her race
she deserves it because she's white
now I don't want to make any assumptions
but I'm willing to bet
that that same exact woman takes offense
to many things
like it is not difficult
to offend that sort of person
but if you're not white and you're
heaping racial scoring on her that
that's when she has a thick skin
that's really the point of the video and
it's why you know you would get similar
answers if you pulled any random
selection of white people in this
country especially younger white people
and especially today after the Great
anti-white Awakening of 2020 white guilt
is an epidemic it's a spiritual and
mental disease afflicting Millions
just think about what these people admit
to believing
that they're not allowed to be proud of
their race but other races can be that
they don't have a culture that they
don't have a racial identity they don't
even have the moral right to object to
being mocked or insulted
it is it's pathetic and sad it's also
terrifying
because nothing good comes from this
there is no happy end there's no um
positive wholesome conclusion
when a society singles out a certain
race in this way points the finger of
blame at it and tells the members of
that race that they don't have the moral
right to feel and act and say things
that other races do
this sort of thing only ever leads to
violence misery catastrophe
as I pointed out before we live in a
culture of self-loathing
white people are taught to hate their
own race boys and girls are taught to
hate and reject their own sex citizens
are taught to hate their own country
kids are taught to hate their own
parents and their own families
is a culture at war with itself
people trying to scratch and Claw their
way out of their own skin
that's not the way to build a
functioning society which is which is
why ours barely functions at all
and so I must say to the white people in
this video though they are they are so
self-loathing that they probably would
agree with me when I say it I'll say it
anyway
that you are all canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]